[Musique]
aujourd'hui chez nous parler de
créativité et pour ça avec moi j'ai
amené un petit appareil jetable
je pense que vous connaissez tous cet
objet dans cet appareil il n'a pas grand
chose pour lui il en plastique
son objectif aussi ils offrent
absolument aucun réglage il a une
pellicule qui est limitée à 27 photos et
vous pouvez vous demander bas à l'heure
où on a tous des téléphones qui prennent
des photos cent fois mieux que ce petit
appareil qu'est ce qu'il a de plus ce
qu'il a de plus cet appareil c'est ce
qu'il a en moins lors d'une expérience
j'ai découvert qu'en fonction des outils
qu'on utilise et de la façon dont on
s'en sert on peut soit stimuler notre
créativité
mais soit complètement la tuer dans mon
cas mais je vous ai expliqué ma théorie
qui consiste à utiliser volontairement
du matériel aux fonctionnalités limitées
pour stimuler sa créativité
donc on va parler de photos mais vous
pouvez appliquer ce que je vais vous
dire aujourd'hui à beaucoup d'autres
disciplines et on va commencer par voir
que sans limite
on va tuer la créativité et donc pour
comprendre ça il faut regarder
aujourd'hui les usages qu'on fait de la
photo aujourd'hui prendre une photo ne
coûte rien ou presque
c'est devenu tellement facile c'est
devenu trop facile quand on a développé
des mauvaises habitudes et or ces
habitudes elles sont si mauvaises
qu'elles nous amène à ce chiffre
ce chiffre de 1200 milliards alors non
c'est pas le déficit du trou de la sécu
pour comprendre à quoi ce chiffre
correspond au coût qu'auront monde 200
ans en arrière lorsque la première photo
a été prise à partir de là bas chaque
jour le nombre de photos augmenter avec
la démocratisation de la photo et des
appareils et donc ça augmenté de façon
constante
par contre là où ça vraiment explosé
c'est dans les années 2000 avec
l'apparition du numérique
là on s'est mis à prendre en photo un
peu tout et n'importe quoi surtout les
chats
et donc à partir de là j'ai lu que en
on apprit 1200 milliards de photos en un
an
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
de l'ampleur ce nombre d'image à
regarder et donc quand on ramène ça on
regarde ça d'une autre perspective
chaque claquement de doigts ça
représente 38 mille photos en plus qui
ont été prises dans achat claquement de
doigts vous rajoutez 38 mille photos
donc si tout va bien d'ici dix minutes
j'aurais terminé mon speech et il y aura
environ avait un peu plus de 20 millions
de nouvelles photos qui ont été prises
dans le monde 20 millions de photos et
alors ce chiffre un peu absurde il
s'explique par une pratique bien connue
par les photographes ça même à mots en
anglais
c'est ce qu'on appelle le sprix entre
donc le spray et le prêt de prier
imaginez vous êtes chez vous tranquille
dans votre lycée l'été cheveux fenêtres
ouvertes petite brise est là
entendez le moustique qui arrive alors
vous mettez de trois baffes voyez que ça
marche pas et alors qu'est ce que vous
faites vous sortez la bombe aérosol et
alors là vous êtes énervé vous envie de
dormir vous mettez de la bande partout
partout partout partout et vous est fixé
vous même et pendant ce temps là bas le
moustique qui courent toujours
et du coup mais ça je trouve que ça
colle parfaitement avec la façon dont
beaucoup d'entre nous et moi le premier
j'en étais coupable d'aborder la photo
on va se mettre à prendre un peu tout et
n'importe quoi en photo et sans trop
réfléchir
et ça ça va causer de la frustration et
cette frustration mais fabricant
d'appareils photo et ont bien compris
parce que chaque semaine ils nous
sortent un nouvel appareil avec une
fonctionnalité on savait pas qu'on en
avait besoin jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais là
il nous la faut absolument il ya
toujours plus de pixels toujours plus
voilà de fonction et ont semé persuadé
qu'on a absolument besoin de ce nouvel
appareil pour progresser en photo donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va trouver
des excuses da pour justifier l'achat
d'un nouvel appareil plutôt que
d'essayer de comprendre d'utiliser un
peu l'appareil qu'on a déjà et de
repousser les limites et c'est un peu
cette façon d'aborder la photo qui un
jour m'a dégoûté et j'ai fait comme un
burn-out plus aucune envie de de prendre
une photo plus l'envié de passer plus de
temps devant mon ordinateur à trier à
éditer ses photos qui avait pas grand
sens et du coup j'ai fait un break
pendant ce temps là bas mes appareils
sont restés au placard et moi ça m'a
permis de réfléchir ça m'a permis de
comprendre que j'avais besoin de revenir
à une façon plus simple une façon plus
authentique d'aborder la photo alors
c'est vrai qu'à un moment pour me
remotiver j'ai été tenté d'acheter un
nouvel appareil nous un nouvel objectif
mais je savais d'emblée que ça allait
pas marcher une faille il fallait un
changement radical et à ce moment là bas
j'ai décidé nous diriger vers
l'argentique et donc maintenant je vais
vous montrer comment en faisant se
limitant en réduisant les options qui
nous sont offertes on va stimuler notre
créativité pour revenir un autre
un autre petit jetables j'ai fait une
expérience intéressante lors d'un voyage
avec des amis donc on est parti en
islande ensemble pendant quinze jours et
donc avec mes super appareil photo belge
était le photographe officiel des
vacances donc je me prenais tout en
photo mais je me suis dit quand même
avant de partir ça serait sympa d'un
petit jetables qu'on pourrait se
partager qu'on aurait tous à notre
disposition et ça nous ferait des photos
à redécouvrir plus tard une fois les
vacances finies
alors ces photos bon bah c'est
certainement l'est pas
et plus spectaculaire que vous avez dû
voir d'islande mais déjà bassam à cette
expérience m'a appris deux choses la
première c'est que mes amis ils sont pas
capables de prendre de bonnes photos
alors je donne une conférence sur
comment perdre ses amis en cinq minutes
après si ça vous intéresse
mais surtout ce que l'enseignement que
j'en ai tiré c'est que avec un nombre de
photos limité en avance on a été forcé
de se poser au moins une question avant
de déclencher et c est ce que ce moment
mérite d'être pris en photo est ce que
j'ai envie de garder un souvenir de ce
moment et donc comme je lui ai dit voilà
ces photos c'est pas les plus
spectaculaires mais c'est sûrement celle
qui nous ont fait le plus rigoler et
qu'on a pris le plus de plaisir à revoir
ensemble
alors oui c'est sûr que c'est plus
facile de regarder ses 24 autos que les
3000 que j'ai ramené avec numérique mais
surtout voilà c'était vraiment le fait
de se poser une question de savoir qu'on
n'avait pas le choix il fallait faire le
maximum pour chacune d'entre elles
donc ça n'a pas marché pour tout mais
pour la plupart on a eu quand même des
photos marrantes et qu'on apprivoise du
plaisir à regarder et de cette
expérience est né un vrai intérêt pour
la photo argentique une vraie curiosité
et donc rapidement après je me suis
acheté mon premier vrai appareil
argentique et c'est en développant et en
récupérant les premières photos prises
avec cet appareil que j'ai eu la
révélation
déjà c'est un appareil mécanique c'est
pas bourré d'électronique d'écran c'est
tout c'est comme une montre suisse
ensuite il faut charger sa pellicule
donc ça commence à nous donner
conscience de la valeur des images
ensuite on avance chaque image une après
l'autre
on rembobine et après il faut mais cette
pellicule au labo donc la donne au labo
est là on attend on attend en attend et
là il ya finalement le coup de fil du
labo qui nous dit que les photos sont
traite donc c'est comme un enfant qui va
découvrir ses cadeaux de noël finalement
est donc là on en arrive aux labos on
récupère les photos et on les découvre
sur papier pour la première fois et là
j'ai pris une vraie claque
particulièrement voyant cette photo de
ma moitié
j'ai su que je voulais que mes photos
ressemblent à ça je savais j'ai compte
trouver la direction que je voulais
prendre et je savais que c'est ce que je
voulais faire
donc là sur un coup de tête j'ai pris
une décision assez radicales pour moi à
l'époque j'ai décidé de vendre tout le
matériel photo que j'avais accumulé
depuis des années ça représente quand
même une sacrée montagne de tout vendre
d'un coup et de me consacrer à
l'argentique pendant au moins un an
j'ai décidé de me l'an
c'est un défi pour sortir de ma zone de
confort de mon train-train et de me
consacrer à l'argentique voilà pendant
au moins une année entière je n'avais
pas nous amènerait je savais pas si
j'allais reprendre le numérique après ou
pas et en fait ce que je recherchais à
l'époque c'étaient des contraintes des
limites il fallait que je vois là que je
ressorte je sors de ma zone de confort
et à l'époque j'ai trouvé les
contraintes imposées par l'argentique
intéressantes comme j'ai dit on est
limité par le nombre de photos donc on
va là en des gens risquent pas de
rentrer de vacances avec 3000 photos à
développer on va faire attention à
chacune de ces photos on va forcer la
réflexion parce que chaque photo est
importante donc on va faire attention à
notre cadre on va regarder si nos
réglages sont bons si le sourire de la
personne et si c'est le bon moment
ensuite on ralentit ses des appareils
qui sont mécaniques souvent il ya ils
ont rarement tous ces modes automatiques
qui font tout pour vous l'appareil est
en général est complètement manuel la
mise au point les réglages la lumière
donc ça baisse ça nous force à ralentir
à profiter de l'instant présent et pas
être là ni trahi et tout et n'importe
quoi sans sans but précis et ensuite le
fait que c'est déjà ça va nous donner de
la valeur supplémentaire à nos photos
alors chacune de chaque pellicule coût
de l'argent chaque photo chaque
développement ne s'est pas de cette
valeur là dont je vous parlais
c'est la valeur qu'on aura donné à notre
image qu'est-ce qu'on aura voulu en
faire toute la réflexion qui aura eu
derrière c'est ça la vraie valeur et
c'est cette image là qu on sera content
de redécouvrir qui commencera finalement
développé et le dernier point qui m'a le
plus séduit à l'époque donc un moment où
je passais ma journée dans un bureau
entouré de deux imac énorme je passais
voilà ma vie derrière des écrans donc
derrière un écran au travail d un écran
derrière mon appareil vers un écran en
train d'éditer et j'avais besoin
vraiment de me déconnecter de ces écrans
est donc maintenant qu'on a vu comment
stimuler notre créativité
on va faire une petite activité je vais
vous montrer comment on va maintenant
libéré notre créativité
alors pour ça je vous demander à tous de
vous mettre dans la peau d'un
photographe pendant quelques instants
et je vais vous lancer un défi à tous
moi je vais être le jury et vous vous
allez devoir me présenter la meilleure
photo possible
alors comme je suis sympa je vais vous
laisser carte blanche vous allez pouvoir
choisir le sujet de votre photo ce qui
vous fait ce qui vous fait plaisir
vous voulez prendre cette photo si vous
voulez apprendre ici ça me va mais s'ils
voulaient prendre un billet d'avion l
apprendre à l'aube du monde
allez-y faites vous plaisir vous pouvez
aussi choisir le matériel que vous
voulez si vous voulez tel appareil est l
objectif un trépied de l'éclairage peu
importe vous êtes libre de choisir ce
que vous voulez la seule contrainte que
je vais vous imposez sais que je vais
vous donner une heure à partir de
maintenant pour prendre votre photo et
me rendre la meilleure photo possible
donc je ne sais pas s'il ya des
photographes c'est beaucoup de
photographes dans la salle et je pense
pas que beaucoup d'entre vous et déjà le
projet défini dans leur tête et moi si
je me retrouve devant un défi de cette
sorte
je vais être un peu paumé dans mes choix
je vais avoir du mal à prendre une
direction
je vais être perdus par le nombre de
possibilités qui nous sont offertes
je vais devoir trouver une idée ensuite
il va savoir quel pouvoir savoir quel
appareil je vais utiliser
est-ce que ça va je vais en faire une
photo noir et blanc une photo couleur
combien de photos je vais prendre je
vais devoir les trier et leur que je
vous aurais donné elle va passer très
très vite
et pendant cette heure là vous allez
passer pas mal de temps à résoudre à
résoudre des problèmes plutôt qu'à
laisser parler votre créativité la
créativité elle va rester sur le carreau
pendant quasiment tout leur vous pensez
que vous avez rendu service en nous
laissant carte blanche mais en fait j'ai
pas été très sympa donc j'essaie de me
racheter un peu on va refaire le même
défi mais cette fois on va les pistes et
un petit peu donc maintenant je vais
choisir pour vous le sujet je vais
choisir le lieu et le matériel donc le
sujet ben j'ai pris au hasard ma mère
ici présente donc vous allez devoir
faire le meilleur portrait de ma mère
possible et attention je m exigent donc
vous allez devoir intérêt d'être créatif
le lieu ça va être ici et le matériel
donc j'ai pris un appareil qui lui offre
les fonctions basiques pour prendre une
photo ni plus ni moins c'est un objectif
avec un angle fixe et il fait des photos
c'est tout je vais vous donner aussi une
pellicule photo donc qui est limité à 36
poses et qui en noir et blanc
donc là ça commence je pensais aller
mieux dans votre tête vous commencez
déjà avoir une idée a de quoi la photo
pourrait ressembler et surtout ce qui va
se passer c'est que pendant sept heures
vous allez pouvoir consacrer toute votre
énergie votre créativité à tirer le
maximum de chacune de ces
36 photos vous pouvez prendre vous aurez
très peu de problèmes à résoudre et vous
allez pouvoir trouver des idées tester
des éclairages des pauses et c'est là
que vous allez vraiment progressé on
s'en rend pas forcément compte mais tous
les jours on doit prendre des centaines
de décisions conscientes ou non
donc autant simplifier un petit peu la
tâche quand on essaie d'être créatif
quand je partais en voyage j'ai emporté
avec moi tout mon matos photo et croyez
moi ça faisait quand même un sacré
bordel sur le dos à porter je voulais
juste ne pas manquer une occasion donc
j'avais tout avec moi mais deux
appareils tous mes objectifs
nab au moins cinq ou six j'avais mon
flash mon trépied vaste et ma femme qui
le porte et j'avais les réflecteurs les
filtres et ce qui se passait c'est que
au début j'avais pris la photo comme une
excuse pour voyager et en fait je
passais mes voyages
derrière mon écran derrière mon écran à
regarder mes photos le soir on rentrer à
l'hôtel
est ce que je faisais il fallait que des
charges les cartes mémoires donc je veux
passer encore plus de temps à en plus à
trimballer mes disques durs mon ordi et
le sort il faut aller recharger les
batteries
donc j'ai rechargé les batteries des
appareils mais pas vraiment les miennes
et donc tout ça c'est pour vous montrer
que si on veut être créatif on a besoin
des fois de sortir nos zones de confort
et de s'imposer des limites et je
terminerai juste avec une petite
citation que j'aime bien je trouve qu'il
colle bien avec ça aujourd'hui une
citation d'einstein c'est que la folie
c'est faire toujours la même chose et
s'attendre à un résultat différent
[Applaudissements]
d où transitent ces contacts que ce
moment mérite un souvenir si vous
permettez 6
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]